والصين ترد باختراقات جوية
ومناورات عسكرية. فهل هذا الرد
على التليفزيون الحكومي. ويعشق
اللاعب السابق وين راني? فماذا
بلاد الرافدين تستسلم للجفاف
بسبب ارتفاع الحرارة وقلة
التعامل مع الحركة كجهة رسمية في
المحافل الدولية. يا الهي عشرون
واليوم تتعامل معها كجهة رسمية
ما اقبح المصالح السياسية. جنات
عن النهائيات النووية? امريكا
تستفز الصين للمرة الثانية
الشياطين الحمر في الدوري
الانجليزي ويبث جميع مبارياته
الموقف الاسباني تجاه القضية
الصحراوية. واكدت الشركة
مكان الوثائق التي عثر عليها
بحوزته ليعلق ترامب قائلا لمكتب
ايران حول ملفها النووي داعية
واشنطن الى ابداء المرونة لاحياء
السابق هو من ابلغ مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي اف بي اي عن
اخرى دون وقوع خسائر. قال وزير
الخارجية الافغانية ميرخان متقي
من جنسيات مختلفة في اوكرانيا.
استهدف هجوم بطائرات مسيرة موقعا
الامطار. ومن جفاف الى الجفاف
السياسي. حيث رفع التيار الصدري
الروس للابتزاز النووي ومن حقنا
استهداف الروس الذين يحتمون بها.
ان حركة طالبان تمكنت من اقامة
علاقات سياسية متوازنة ورسمية مع
دعوى قضائية ضد الرئاسات الثلاث
وتحركات لتحالف الفتح لاطلاق
مبادرة لحل الازمة العراقية.
زعيم كوريا الشمالية يشجع
عاما احتلت فيها امريكا
افغانستان بحجة محاربة طالبان
العراق تتحول من ارض وفيرة
بالمياه الى يابسة قاحلة. ابار
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية ونحو
ست عشرة دولة اخرى. وانه تم
عسكريا امريكيا بمنطقة التنف عند
الحدود السورية العراقية وقال
المحادثات ليعتبر وزير الخارجية
الايراني حسين امير عبدالهيان ان
خرسون مضيفة ان ضربات عالية
الدقة تمكنت من قتل مائة مرتزق
الفشل في احياء الاتفاق لن يكون
نهاية العالم. الاحداث الجزائر
الجيش الامريكي انه تم اسقاط
احدى المسيرات المهاجمة واعتراض
اذ تواصل الجزائر خفض صادراتها
من الغاز نحو اسبانيا بعد الازمة
الدبلوماسية التي اندلعت بين
البلدين في مارس الماضي عقب تغير
متطورة. وهذا العرض للدول
الصديقة والتي تتفق مع سياساتها.
مليار روبل لننتقل الى شبح
زابروتش. وللمرة الرابعة تتجدد
البشرية. حراج بوتين النووي.
تطوير التعاون مع شركاء موسكو
المتبقية فلا خوف على طهران.
فلها خطط بديلة اذا اخفقت
الادوار بين اول وثاني اكبر دولة
مصدرة للسلاح في العالم. لتعلق
وثلاثين منشأة تابعة للقوات
الاوكرانية المتمركزة على حدود
بداية العام الحالي. اعلنت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية تدمير خمس
الاسبانية ان واردات الغاز
الجزائري تراجعت بنسبة خمسين منذ
تضع يدها بيد موسكو وتستخدم
اساليب بوتين في معاقبة اوروبا.
اخرى. ولكن لماذا تشتري روسيا
طائرات ايران المسيرة وهي تتبادل
تثير قلقا متزايدا لدى واشنطن
وحلفائها الاوروبيين. واعادت ملف
يتظاهرون بالسلاح امام مكتب
المباحث الفيدرالية في امريكا.
الدفاع الصاروخي الامريكي
الاوروبي الى جدول الاعمال مرة
موسكو وطهران والمتعلقة
بالطائرات المسيرة الايرانية
البيت الابيض. ولم نخرق القانون
ليظهر هنا مؤيدو ترامب وهم
كشف مسؤولون في وقت سابق ان شخصا
من الدائرة المقربة من الرئيس
بينها مواد عن الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون. مكتب التحقيقات
ترامب لتتدخل هنا ابنة دونالد
ترامب معتقدة ان الشخص الذي ابلغ
فتيلها? صفقة ايران المرعبة.
يبدو ان الصفقة المحتملة بين
الاتفاق وانه اذا رفضت واشنطن
ابداء مرونة في حل المسائل
فهل ستنشب هنا حرب اهلية يحمل
الرجل الاصفر مسئولية اشعال
يوجد حاليا اي يمكن العلماء من
معرفة سرعة تناقله بين البشر.
يضرب هذا الفيروس الجهاز العصبي.
وافادت وزارة الصحة في الصين عن
اصابة خمسة وثلاثين شخصا في
مقاطعتين كان اغلبهم ممن يتعامل
صفيح ساخن. الرد العسكري جاء
اسرع من الرد الدبلوماسي اذ
باعلان مناورات عسكرية. ما هذا
الرد الساحق لقد اهدرت الصين في
التحقيقات الفيدرالي. الوثائق
صادرة رفعت عنها سرية قبل مغادرة
بالكامل تجنبا بكارثة نووية.
ليرد زلانسكي ان محطة زابروتش
الفيدرالي يرفع السرية عن مذكرة
التفتيش الخاصة بمداهمة منزل
تتراشقها كييف وموسكو لتبادر
روسيا وتقترح ايقاف المحطة
الاشتباكات في محيطها لتدق ناقوس
الخطر. الاتهامات المتبادلة
ويا لرجاحة فبيكلمتين منك بعت
باكثر من خمسمائة واثنين وعشرين
الضخمة برأيكم هل افتتحت روسيا
حراجا نوويا? يا لخبثك يا بوتين
عن احتفاظ عمه بوثائق في مقر
اقامته هو صهره جيرت كوشنر حيث
صناديق ترامب. احدى عشرة وثيقة
صنف بعضها سري للغاية كما كان
مع الحيوانات. والذي يرجح ان
سببه ما يعرف بفأر الذباب حيث لا
مليار روبل. لكن من هي هذه الدول
التي اشترت بكل هذه المبالغ
عن فيروس جديد يهدد البشرية
والاصابات في تزايد مستمر.
وطائرة مسيرة تستهدف قواعد
امريكية. فمن الفاعل؟ ترامب
ان بلاده تقدر علاقاتها مع دول
في امريكا اللاتينية واسيا
يكتشف الخائن. وما علاقة وزع
كوريا الشمالية بالشياطين الحمر.
وافريقيا وانها مستعدة لتزويد
حلفائها باسلحة حديثة وبقدرات
لقد اصبحت الصين تنافس هواتف ابل
وسامسونج في اصداراتها فهي تعلن
ان الصين ستواصل الدفاع عن سيادة
اراضيها. ومن رائحة البارود الى
بيع مع ست وثلاثين دولة بقيمة
تتجاوز خمسمائة واثنين وعشرين
الثانية. فالى متى ستهدرون
الوقود والذخيرة في الاجواء
العسكريين سيؤدي الى الاستقرار
في العالم اجمع. كلمات تغنى بها
وعلى الهامش فقد اعلنت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية انها وقعت عقود
ويعلن الاستعداد الكامل لتسليح
الحلفاء. حيث قال الرئيس الروسي
الخالية ليصرح بعدها المندوب
الصيني لدى الامم المتحدة بدعوته
مناوراتها مع تايوان ذخيرة اكثر
مما تم اهداره في الحرب العالمية
الاخيرة. الصين على صفيح ساخن.
لم يكد يمضي اثنا عشر يوما على
الفيديو السابق كيف سترد الصين
واليوم الرد الصيني ياتي على
زيارة الباسوس نانسي بيلوسي
لتايوان حتى وصل وفد من الكونجرس
بوتين في منتدى موسكو العسكري
الدولي ليتفاخر بالسلاح الروسي
لنا كل عام عن فيروس جديد
وبمزايا جديدة قد تنهي حياة
يكفي لكبح جماح ابناء العم سام?
الادارة الامريكية الى التوقف عن
السير في الاتجاه الخاطئ. مؤكدا
الى الجزيرة مجددا رغم كل الجدل
والتداعيات. وقد تساءلنا في
الكريملين لمعاقبة الدول غير
صديقة. والعراق يلفظ انفاسه
من يريد السلاح فليأتي الى روسيا
ومن ليس له حليف. نحن حلفاؤه.
الحرب الجرثومية اذ اعلنت الصين
عن فيروس جديد وقاتل اسمه حيث
هكذا قالها بوتين بحضور اكثر من
اثنتين وثمانين دولة. الصين تعلن
اخترقت المقاتلات الصينية
الاجواء التايوانية وتسابق الزمن
وصفقة ايرانية روسية جديدة تقلق
الغرب والجزائر تستخدم نظرية ابن